peu
[Musique]
ah ah
à
[Musique]
1875 la révolte gronde dans les terres
de sibérie où les tribus tartare la
conduite d'yves en augareils ancien
colonel de l'armée impériale et de fait
aux farc en prince tartare du turkestan
contrôle déjà des provinces entières
le capitaine michel strogoff est chargé
par le tsar alexandre 2 une périlleuse
mission
traverser cinq mille kilomètres de pays
hostiles pour atteindre irkoutsk où le
frère du tsar se trouve menacée par les
rebelles le train qui emmène le courrier
du tsar vers les monts oil va permettre
à celui-ci de rencontre et nadia fille
d'un déporté politique qui elle aussi
s'efforce de gagner la sibérie pour
rejoindre son père afin de passer plus
facilement inaperçu aux yeux des espions
de greef strogoff oppose à nadia de
voyager avec lui en la faisant passer
pour sa femme
la jeune fille accepte les animaux ni
novgorod où s'arrête la voie ferrée les
difficultés commencent en bateau d'abord
puis en voiture
le courrier du tsar et sa compagne
tentent de gagner l'oural quand ils y
parviennent enfin les éléments se
mettent de la partie et un orage
particulièrement violent les clous sur
les pentes escarpées de la montat
[Musique]
attention
au palais léon mba
les deux roues essayé de couper les
harnais
[Musique]
fait jeter tel ce choix assez mal
revolver donnez-moi le revolver vite
[Applaudissements]
ça
vaut mieux éviter de souffrir
alors partons restons pas ici
[Musique]
très bien
abritée lui ça va mieux je cherchais le
cheval rester ici attendez-moi garder
nos jeunes verts je reviens tout de
suite
[Musique]
m
lee
[Applaudissements]
coop
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
alors ces normes nous étions abrités il
a surgit soudain dans la nuit et nous
n'avons en l'air tout faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
je veux faire massacrer
[Musique]
ça me demandez si vous n'aviez pas
raison à 15 kg
cet homme là n'est pas ordinaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cela ne peut pas être un hasard que nous
le trouverons toujours sur la même route
que nous en tout cas dorénavant ce ne
sera plus un hasard je vous le garantis
attacher solidement
une espèce d'attelage que nous employons
très souvent dans l'art dans nos
provinces sibérienne pour suppléer le
manque de chevaux
nous sommes au sommet du col
ekaterinbourg se trouve juste en bas
ça tient va jusqu'en bas nadia
[Musique]
cette région
vous avez des chevaux oui il m'en reste
quelques-uns mais s'attend sûrement les
derniers produits thézan on m'annonce
plusieurs régiments de kozak qui vont
prendre tout ce qui est en cause a qui
s'en est suivie une autre état major a
choisi et catherine bourg comme source
de toutes les troupes ils vont partir en
guerre contre des tartares rebelles ils
combien de temps pour réparer tout la
capote qui a été arrachée 24 heures a
changé les chevaux et vérifier les
harnais et tout l'attelage cette fois
j'espère que vous nous fait le plaisir
de déjeuner avec nous combien de temps
pour trouver environ deux heures par
mois alors j'accepte avec grand plaisir
il paraît que la cuisine est très bonne
chez toi c'est vrai elle est une chose
qu'on dit messieurs mai mais qu'est ce
qu'il ya je n'ai pas de tables libres
mais celle ci est cette dame attend 3
messieurs
cela va très bien nous sommes justement
trois bonjour madame
elle nous vous prions d'accepter nos
otages permettez nous de partager votre
repas je vous prie de toute cette table
immédiatement vous est cruel vous
n'allez pas chassés de pauvres aux
officines et il existe plus d'un moyen
pour apprivoiser les folles pour marie
sera là d'un moment à l'autre et ce
n'est pas un homme à se laisser offensé
[Musique]
oui bien sûr non il faut il faut en
fabriquer un autre non non non il faut
rien les pari fou de changer et entendu
monsieur changera tout le déjeuner
veulent être prêts dans cinq minutes
ah je remercie la rue des marines où les
ados surtout quand ce sont des jeunes du
doigt la saison face à ce terrible
marque un fameux chevalier que vous avez
là monsieur conduite est indigne de jack
je vous prie de quitter immédiatement la
table de madame je vous en prie allez ma
belle rejoindre ce pôle trop de marie et
bien boris c'est cette femme qui 30 ou
pensif
non plutôt son mari enfin nous l'avons à
peine une démarche toute cette
silhouette rappelle quelqu'un qui sape
michel strogoff n'ai rien à vous dire
allez lui font moins peur que les hommes
et deux choses l'une ou bien c'est un
lâche
il craint terriblement d'être reconnu au
garage dont nous parlions a été officié
dans la mer mon public il est à moitié
tartare cet homme là n'a rien
d'asiatique grand mère yolande c'est ce
que ça se boit rbc nous pouvons pas
perdre ces traces que nous soyons bien
de faire atteler rapidement
il fait de rester à catherine baud je ne
vous ai rien demandé rien demander ne
demandait rien à personne pour vous les
autres n'existent pas mais j'existe moi
je vois bien
qu'avez vous à dire je pense que si
quelqu'un doit dire quelque chose ce
qu'elle casse est justement vous non
n'ai rien à dire
[Musique]
oui c'est trop facile de jouer les
sommes supérieures autres cantons a
laissé trois voyous se moquer d'une
femme ça je m'y attendais n'ai pas de
comptes à bourran n'y a personne
le prouver croire m'intéresse pas oui
dans ce cas je vais vous le dire ce que
je pense de moi je pense que cet ignoble
marchands du train avait raison je pense
que si la police vous recherche
elle assure mardi réseau je pense une
sorte de pauvres aventuriers capable de
tout et de rien que vous vous servez des
autres comme des objets pour vous la
seule chose qui est important c'est de
fuir ceux qui sont en recherche
voilà ce que je vous déteste
bonjour bonjour vos papiers s'il vous
plaît voulait me donner vos passeports
les voeux à homs
vous feriez beaucoup mieux de ne pas
continuer amazon que vous abordez nous
ne contrôlons plus la situation et les
routes ne sont pas sûres surtout
lorsqu'on voyage avec une très jolie
femme
merci il nous faut passer un votre aise
et bonne chance
[Musique]
c'est vous pensez vraiment tout ce que
vous m'avez dit pourquoi ne pas m'avoir
dénoncer via
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
on approche
je connais une ferme en ruine nous
allons étendre les nuits
[Musique]
m
tout ira bien la nuit est tombée dans
une heure nous pourrons reprendre notre
route et à 10 heures on aura déjà
dépassé la zone des gardes-frontières et
gardes-frontières sont ils à une verte
d'ici vous devriez vous cacher ils vont
certainement tout fouillé par ici
combien sont ils au moins deux douzaines
avec un officier retourne au chariot ne
bouge pas et laisse très fouillée bon
ils n'ont aucune raison de venir ici
s'ils viennent quand même je vendrai
cher ma peau je t'en supplie g20 a juste
eu des bruits ça va
qu'est ce que vous faites là qu'est ce
que ça peut vous faire la toile chariot
dehors les seuls oui c'est dommage quand
on est une jolie fille comme soi ou bien
est-ce que tu ne serait pas seul c'est
un coup d'oeil toi menteuse
[Musique]
tottenham serait misérable
je te ferai châtié partant d'officier
qu'est ce qui se passe ici y'a que l'un
de vos hommes se comportent comme un
vrai soudas voyez que j'en suis désolé
attends moi deux heures madame vous
n'avez plus rien à craindre
où allez-vous à tyumen et pour y faire
quoi
segan avant l'habitude d'aller au hasard
comme bon vous semble vous permettez que
je jette un coup d'oeil
vous cherchez quelque chose nous
cherchons un traître
pensant qu'il s'est caché dans les
parages maintenant vous croyez vraiment
que cet art art sont une menace sort de
la russie vous intéresse mon amant
écoles allen dans l'armée impériale
je voulais vais quitter
rien ni personne ne peut priver les
tsiganes de liberté il n'y a rien dans
le chariot
bon voyage
elle est une femme mariée
ils sont tous partis jamais eu si peur
de toute ma chienne de vie
parce que les chevaux sont prêts oui et
non on ne risque rien la route est libre
une tare entassés prévu à tioumen team
ghost conduira tu dois te rappeler ce
que je te dis à propos de ce courrier du
de sa banque il existe je ne serai pas
tranquille je te rejoindre à omsk quand
tu as appris la ville soit prudent revan
le sort te protège
d'abord mais excusez moi quoi
sommes-nous le relais de poste de
toulouse hinske n'est plus très loin
vous croyez qu'on va y trouver des
chevaux ça n'en sais rien et si on n'en
trouve pas la torture comme ça tient le
relais là bas et
et est quelqu'un y a personne
peut-être que ces gens dorment encore
attendez moi là je vais aller voir
[Musique]
il avait pas
pourquoi nous ferions mieux de repartir
je ne suis pas si fragile je veux savent
pas
mais vraiment
c'est monstrueux
[Musique]
l'état peut être allons nous aller comme
ça pourquoi pas le plus vite sera le
mieux
mais qu'il sorte d'homme êtes vous et
c'est ainsi des morts sans sépulture
essayer de comprendre ce que je vous ai
déjà expliqué des affaires de la plus
haute importance m'appelle d'urgence à
irkoutsk c'est vraiment le moment de
penser aux affaires allez vous dire si
vous ne voulez pas rester
très bien je vais le faire pour vous
allez vous reposer un moment
[Musique]
sans gardien
je suis avec le colonel colonel au
greffe nous attendions avec beaucoup
d'impatience
vous n'êtes pas tartare non j'ai
pourtant choisi votre camp
je suis le maître d'école du village
l'administration russe a pourri ce pays
comme elle pourrit toutes les régions
elle touche je suis avec tous ceux qui
luttent pour que la sibérie puisse être
rendue au peuple tartare par ici
colonels ela wazières elle est dans le
hangar elle vous attend est sans aucun
doute colonel le colosse a des pieds
d'argile dans ce corps immense la
corruption a fait des ravages
c'est pourquoi vo par cannes a
facilement battu les cosaques
hâtez-vous colonel vous avez des
informations précises fait of arcana
atteint les demies palatine ce qui
marche déjà sur oms et il est très bon
elles se rassemblent autour d'omsk où
les chefs vous attendre colonel pour la
grande offensive
et soit dit entre nous colonel ce fut au
phare kahn va trop vite
nous sommes tous pressés
adieu je me souviendrai toujours
[Musique]
ça y est nous pouvons bâtir des tartares
ne doivent pas être très loin
c'est la révolte des tribus est devenu
général ils sont partout mais nos
soldats qu'est ce qu'ils font mon père
disait toujours que nos généraux pensent
plus à leur intérêt qu'à celui de l'
empire et qui sont capables de conduire
une guerre safak tenant qu'il soit en
sibérie dieu vous bénisse et vous
inspire de la pitié pour un pauvre
moines qui ne vit sur cette terre que
des seuls au bol des chrétiens
charitable saint-chrysostome te le
rendra dites-nous mon père est ce que
vous avez lu des tartares le seigneur
m'a dit occupe toi seulement de ta
maison et l'est en voisin en paix
s'occuper de la sienne encore un effort
monfils pourtant propre bien car qui
donne aux pauvres s'enrichit allons un
effort
son jeu que tu trouves ton âme du pays
les chevaux craplet dieu aime les mavs l
art ans et l'on doit avoir beaucoup
péché afin d'être beaucoup part d'un jeu
ce sont là de bons chevaux mme kim
épargneront beaucoup de fatigue
allez-y mes enfants
saint-chrysostome que je te remercie mon
fils me voient sont les livres et de la
mauvaise influence de ces craintes le
relève poste c'est toi qui l'appuyaient
pas vrai je les fais pour dieu et pour
l'empereur le maître de poste avait des
sympathies pour les tartares et qu'as tu
fait des chevaux ils ont les chevaux
j'ai besoin de deux chaufferies tu me
laisses la cie s'il te plaît en échange
quand les crapules je veux les autres et
tout de suite eu les araméens compris
mon ami je t'en prie de grâce ne place
mais j'ignorais que vous étiez bon
soldat
je suis vivant je me semble n est ce pas
vous qui m'avez sauvé la vie oui non je
ne sais pas faire de belles phrases je
peux quand même dire merci je suis un
homme je ne me pardonnerai jamais à
bordi pas un homme c'est à dieu d'en
décider pas nous mais tout à mon père
j'avais cru qu'il me protégerait
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
k
[Musique]
c'est la route l'équipe gestion dans une
heure
regardez une voiture qui nous précèdent
je craignais
absolument que nous arrivions avant le
haïk ims est notre seule chance de voir
des chevaux frais je serai le premier
oh
alé lô
[Musique]
k
et
allez
[Musique]
k
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas la peine que vous restez ici
je vous le répète je n'ai plus ni
chevaux ni voiture ni aucun moyen de
transport il ne me reste absolument rien
c'est la guerre messieurs je regrette de
ne pouvoir vous donner autre chose à
manger que ces quelques restes mais
aussi de mai nous mettons la clé sous la
porte
moi je ne fais rien du moment que nous
avons des chevaux que le chef de poste
c'est moi marine at-elle de chevaux ma
voiture je suis désolé marine mais vous
arrivez trop tard je viens de donner mes
deux derniers faux à ce monsieur
détalaient pour les appeler à ma voiture
ne sais pas si ce monsieur sera d'accord
avec ce que vous proposez quel sera
votre prix monsieur j'ai besoin de ces
deux shows je n'ai pas l'intention de
marchander
que voulez vous
ces chevaux nous sont pas à vendre un
point c'est tout vous avez tort de vous
obstinez jaurès et chevaux de toutes
manières
[Musique]
que voulez vous dire par là
je vais prendre est quoi qu'il arrive
[Musique]
c'est à dire je les prendrais de force
si c'est nécessaire
[Applaudissements]
cette paire de chevaux et bien à moi
tant pis
vous l'aurez vous
regrette mais vu les forcer à t-elle
mois ses chevaux
[Musique]
sans les chevaux ça ne vous en faites
pas je me suis arrangée pour lui refiler
les vieux des sites un truc de notre
métier une potion montante que je leur
ai donné avec sage fall fourbus prend
les allures d'un vrai cheval de course
mais par longtemps les bons chevaux sont
à votre voiture
ah ah dans ce cas nous n'avons qu'à
partir vous ne vous posez pas du tout je
ne suis pas fatigué dame non madame non
plus venez partant allez allez
mais bon sang de bon sang ces chevaux
sont des carnets de boucherie j'ai beau
taper dessus ils n'avancent pas inutile
d'un gosse tu ne sers à rien c'est chaud
nous aurions dû nous méfier de ce petit
maître de poste il n'a pas attiré
juillet à ce que je lui mette la main
dessus rien des colonels ce sont les
nôtres et mousse
des tribus en marche vers tomsk
il ya bien longtemps que j'attendais ce
moment
[Musique]
au revoir jean gosse retourne auprès de
sa gare
[Musique]
nicolas je voulais vous dire à l'auberge
j'ai tout compris y est et je ne poserai
jamais plus aux conditions les tartares
sont très proches hommes ce que n'est
pas loin il fouilla travaux rue nous
allons bientôt y arrive
mais d'abord il faut franchir vertige
yahoo
[Musique]
oh
jo
[Musique]
tenez les rêves
le bac est là un risque
oui
tout près derrière ce rideau d'art
[Musique]
où sont dont les passeurs
voilà
les personnes
[Musique]
à paris
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et les tartares arrêter le buzz
[Musique]
ciao
nicolas attendait cela donc voici mon
fils chacko chaque où chaque bon joueur
c'est cool ça va ça va et ceux là qui
sont ils les tribus kazakh il vient du
latin cash
raji juillard
comment va le lier aux causes mec bien
colonel bien et nous sommes bien en tout
mon plan de bataille est inscrit sur
cette carte minute par minute
comment sais tu l'avenir les russes me
l'ont appris dans leur école fait un
phare kahn pense que les russes disent
des bêtises il a tort il a tort et je
serai bien le lui montrer où en est-il
avec son arme et ils montent par le sud
en direction de tom tomsk
il s'agit de ne pas se laisser gagner de
vitesse parfait au phare si vous suivez
bien mes instructions
demain je vous le promets on est à ascq
[Musique]
et bien sentir dans c'est pas ça alors
ça monsieur je n'en sais rien et je ne
tiens pas du tout à le savoir
décidez vous vite je ne resterai pas ici
très longtemps trop stupide d'être venu
jusqu'ici pour faire demi tour
quant au prince et à la nage on trouvera
bien un moyen décidez-vous mais si vous
payez moi la course que je m'en aille
c'est bien on en avait parlé nous
restons c'est bien ce que nous avions
convenu si les tartares m'attrape ça me
fera une belle jambe alors tout
naturellement les choses intéressantes
se passe de l'autre côté pour moi je la
ville n'est pas encore prise
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai
on dirait que le diable n'a pas voulu de
lui le voilà qui se réveille on peut
dire jeune homme que vous avez de la
chance que se passe-t-il
n'ayez crainte je ne suis pas le grand
saint pierre est elle ou et elle n'a
bien tu la connais non mais vous n'avez
pas cessé de répéter ce nom là depuis
bientôt deux jours complets deux jours
deux jours les prévenant avec le coucou
à viparis c'est un vrai miracle je n'en
doute pas et j'étais sûr que la mort
était en vous quand je vous ai trouvé
sur la berge je peux vous dire que vous
aviez tout l'air de cadavres abandonnés
le ventre à l'air comme un poisson mort
où est elle je crois qu'ils ont pourri
je n'ai vu quand ils l'ont emmené avec
eux les roms sq omsk alors oms qui a été
pris mais ils ont pris presque au
premier assaut ils ont tout balayé
uniates la citadelle qui résiste encore
résonner vous ne partez pas il faut
avoir posé vous remercie je n'ai pas de
temps à perdre il faut que je parte
vous êtes encore très faible c'est de la
folie vous ne pouvez pas aller loin
une tenue passion aux jambes écoutez moi
si les trains ter ont pris votre nadia
vous ne réussirez pas tout seul elle
alors reprendre
est-ce que vous avez un cheval et
qu'est-ce que j'en ferais il me faut un
cheval
et le plus vite possible vieil ami
aurait peut-être mais l'histoire où est
il vous connaissez omsk
je connais bien cette ville
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
le connais ce suppôt de satan regard
il était dangereux c'est lui qui
commande cette bande de brigands
attention si on bloque et war on a tu
veux faire des achats via le livret du
coin ils ont un fils le corps n'a perdu
de circuler en ville et entrer ou d'en
sortir tant que la citadelle ne sera pas
prise à les films
enfin c'est un fonctionnaire russe les
djeunes mon ami pour un peu d'autorité
que ne ferait pas la plupart des hommes
et beaucoup sont comme roux bluff c'est
la police qui l'a dans le sang se moque
pas mal de savoir qui est son maître et
mon vieil ami le pêcheur a bien raison
cela fait quinze ans qu'il n'a pas mis
les pieds en ville qu'elle connaît trop
bien le caractère des hommes
il ya eu plusieurs fois l'occasion d'en
souffrir le pot attendez moi ne vient
[Musique]
oh
entraînez mois
j
excusez moi
dieudo quitté moscou
cette folle je ne connais pas
je n'ai pas
qui êtes vous je suis ta mère
tu as mais celle du nord connu plus ta
mère
[Musique]
c'est une erreur
ne s'agit sans doute que d'une
ressemblance
mais enfin michel tu es le fils de
pierre aymar fasse trop beau
[Musique]
michaud
c'était en fils si mais pourquoi le
cacher parce qu'il doit avoir ses
raisons
peut-être il ne veut pas qu'on me
reconnaisse et vous l'avez nommé marc
phase iii goff et vous voyez qu'il
s'agit bien là de votre fils nous ne
citerons pas que c'est un nom que je
connais c'est celui d'un officier dans
le corps impériale des courriers junior
excusé mais la ressemblance me trompe ou
ben arfa straub offre vous allez me
faire le plaisir de me suivre jusqu'au
quartier général monsieur
et je laisse sans voix
je ne connais personne de ce nom là vous
n'avez rien à craindre qu loving
capitaine que je porte n'est qu'un
déguisement général korsakov avant que
se retirer dans la citadelle nous a
donné l'ordre de nous habiller en civil
à moi et à quelques-uns de mes camarades
fin d'organiser la résistance
j'étais sûr marché tout à l'heure et
j'ai pu voir la scène quand votre mère a
reconnu son fils vous êtes michel
strogoff courrier du tsar en mission je
ne comprend pas un mot de ce que vous
dites je m'appelle serge ivanoff je suis
commerçant à irkoutsk comme vous voulez
je ferai de même à votre place je
voulais seulement dire pour que vous le
sachiez bien que nous allons vous aider
par tous les moyens possibles je crois
qu'il faut agir très vite la ville
fourmille d'espions au carré famille
sans tarder tous ces hommes sur votre
piste je peux vous le dire je sais
qu'ils sont en train d'interroger votre
mère strogoff courrier du tsar tu es sûr
absolument sur votre excellence tu l'a
arrêté non je n'y ai pensé qu'après le
disparu mais sa mère est entre nos mains
où est l emb a fait la montée venez
on m'a dit que ton fils se cache dans
cette ville ce n'est pas mon fils
écoute petite merde
vraiment je ne lui veux absolument aucun
mal un courrier du tsar est en route
pour la ville d'irkoutsk
il ne doit pas arriver et je t'assure
qu'il n'arrivera pas en m'aidant à le
trouver maintenant tu ne fais que lui
épargner de plus grave danger
je ne sais pas de quoi vous me parlez
très bien tant pis pour toi tant fait
pour lui
[Musique]
aucune brèche
aucune issue nulle part il faut attendre
un ou deux jours le temps de trouver une
issue je n'ai pas de temps à perdre il
faut que je sorte ce soir je ne vois pas
du tout comment vous pouvez me procurer
un cheval oui et de la poudre nous en
avons
moi c'est ce que je vous propose
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
à lui
et au lieu de jouer batman feriez mieux
de venir
il nous a vu les circonstances
combien de se maintenir en forme se
maintenir en forme rien ne vaut un bon
repas les masses sont restés ce votre
cas
baignez vous sent que vous seriez morts
de faim il était dégoûté je vous concède
qu'ils sont meilleurs puis à
[Musique]
bonjour voilà que voulez vous nous
passez de l'autre côté je vous prie si
je peux me permettre de vous donner un
conseil vous feriez mieux je crains de
ne pas traverser la nuit parce que ici
tout plutôt que cela voilà trois jours
que nous sommes ici les tartares ont
pris la ville ils occupent toute la
région de l'autre côté du fleuve
je pense que vous le savez c'est
précisément pourquoi nous voulons gagner
nous sommes journalistes
ce journaliste je voir et vous croyez
vraiment que ça suffit pour être à
l'abri des mauvais coups l'année
dernière quelqu'un a réussi à s'échapper
de la ville et les tartares vont tout
faire pour le reprendre
ils veulent sûrement agir par surprise à
mort commandement au jeune condamné
était un espion du tsar ont vaincu par
jugement d'avoir un rôle dans l'attentât
de la nuit dernière nous exécutons de
mettre tous les espions par contre une
somme de 15 100 roubles sera dûment
remises à tous ceux qui sont
susceptibles de nous dénoncer les
complices ou de nous aider de quelques
manières à la capture de l'autre espion
qui s'est enfui en faisant sauter la
porte sud de la ville et rassemblements
de plus de deux personnes sont interdits
que sais tu de strogoff je sais tout
colonel presque sans mentir je t'écoute
mes parents habitent et une maison
brésil se laisse trop nov - bell bien
sûr il nous étions moins considéré dans
la ville enfin je le regardais vivre de
loin j'admirais beaucoup les qualités
qui étaient les siennes
sa force sa fierté et la manière qu'il
avait de se faire respecter par tous et
lui te connais je suis sûr qu'il m'a
oublié je n'avais rien pour attirer son
regard est cependant ils avaient tort je
suis bien plus intelligent clés tu
pourrais le reconnaître bien sûr je
pourrais reconnaître michel strogoff
même s'il faut pour cela aller au fond
de l'enfer fouiller tout sur votre
passage village maisons fermes isolées
il doit se cacher sur la route
d'irkoutsk celui là va vous permettre de
le reconnaître
où qu'ils se cachent je le veux mort ou
vif
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
j'avais promis de tout rejoint dès que
tu seras emparées de cette ville la
capture et le courrier d'une ça non mais
je suis maintenant sur ses traces qui
sont ces deux là sont deux étrangers
j'ai trouvé aux abords des fortes à
l'extérieur j'ai interdit d'entrer ou de
sortir de la ville
j'ai pensé qu'il pourrait intéresser
sont deux journalistes correspondants de
presse
alors anglais et un français je suis le
colonel au greffe
soyez les bienvenus sur le sol de la
nouvelle république si derrière les
parties hachuré représentent les
territoires déjà libéré par nos troupes
et régie par les lois de la nouvelle
administration républicaine un pays
moderne voilà ce que nous voulons bâtir
sur les ruines de la décadence de
l'empiré on me promenant tout à l'heure
avec vous à travers la ville il m'a
semblé voir le drapeau impérial flotter
sur la citadelle monsieur jolivet cette
citadelle est loin d'avoir la même
portée symbolique que votre bastille
elle tombera comme un fruit mûr
quand le temps sera venu la possession
de ces vastes territoires la libération
de nos tribus opprimés voilà du tangible
monsieur jolivet c'est un réaliste
colonel les y ait parfois des symboles
qui ont plus de résistance que les
forces matérielles vous laissez pas
influencer comme elle ces français sont
tous ces sacrés des analystes je vais
malgré tout à l'heure à vos guerriers et
à tort vous les avez placé comme des
roses cadre vous êtes sur le bon chemin
est ce que le travail est fait par
cannes s'inspire des mêmes principes
chacun de notre côté nous luttons pour
la liberté de notre peuple monsieur
jolivet franchement parler je ne vois
pas comment il sera possible de
concilier vos aspirations républicaines
et les conceptions disons plus médiévale
de fait aux arcanes pour l'instant notre
tâche est de vaincre les armes et du
zares
veuillez m'excuser d'aller patrouille de
reconnaissance sont de retour et je dois
entendre le rapport
je vous accompagnez colonel désiré la
situation militaire
je vous en prie il n'y a rien de secret
au contraire je serai ravi que les
nations occidentales en prennent
connaissance des couacs colonel puisque
nous sommes entre républicains
j'aimerais pas mon journal poursuivre
mon voyage en direction de l'armée de
fait aux femmes oui vous me fournir
laisser passer je ne suis pas sûr que
vous trouviez auprès de l'émir de
boukhara un interlocuteur très
compréhensif mais je vous donnerai votre
sauf conduit monsieur jolivet tenait
monsieur blount avec ce laisser-passer
vous êtes libre d'aller où bon vous
semble
notre précieuse majesté la reine
victoria seront informés avant jour-là
de l'accueil amical que vous avez
réservé un sujet britannique
j'aimerais que votre gouvernement sache
également que notre république compte
entretenir d'excellents rapports avec le
royaume uni
il fera bon voyage mais si blount plus
vous vous posez encore une question mais
je vous en prie
quel est donc ce mystérieux cavaliers
qui a forcé ya les porte couleurs vives
je n'en ai pas la moindre idée monsieur
grint
[Musique]
tiens moi aussi colonel houga les fans
de cinéma kadhafi
et nous nous sommes trompés mystérieux
voyageur n'était pas le colonel houga
réf alors qu'il est utile je pense à ce
cavalier inconnu qui s'est échappé cette
nuit tout cela ne nous dit toujours pas
qu'il y ait une pièce importante dans
cette partie d'échecs soyez en sûr il
est parti vers la wii je crois un peu de
vodka
[Musique]
jamais entre les repas
oh
et sûrement partie par là et c'est le
chemin des marais alors les i moi je
prends pas la route où se retrouvent
tant à la cheville
[Musique]
à temps
on mange pas la manger
double ration debaghine un chrome est
doit vous n'allez pas partir à 7 heures
de l'ennemi si aulas et progrès freedom
marine pour prudent du tout non pourquoi
lorsque le tartan ne le permettent pas
et tartare elle tartare barine je n'ai
pas vu tartare dans ce pays depuis plus
de 30 ans non je parle des loups garous
et des feux follets toulon marais en
sont pleins ils s'en prennent aux
voyageurs si c'est que ça n'en ai pas
peur à vous n'y croyez pas baril et
pourtant moi j'en ai connu des gens
malins que personne n'a jamais retrouvé
bon comme il se doit
12 kopecks avec lavoine comprise pour le
cheval au cha rumba que c'est pour toi
ça vieux
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un cavalier a dû passer chez toi un
cavalier barine je n'ai vu absolument
personne n'avait aucun cavalier tu
ferais mieux de dire la vérité et mon
bonhomme et vite sinon ces messieurs se
feront un plaisir de te faire parler
c'est à dire que maintenant que j'y
pense
1 ça fait à peu près une heure un
voyageur s'est arrêté ici pour manger
il n'est pas resté longtemps leonard dit
oui une heure ou à peine plus
cette fois nous y tenons
[Musique]
à boire pour l'amour tu m'as l'air à
bout de force ne viens-tu d'omsk on m'a
dit que la ville a été prise par les
tartares c'est vrai et où vas-tu sur
l'autre arrive parce que les tartares
n'y sont pas déjà
[Musique]
merci merci pour tout il faut que je
parte que dieu te garde il n'y a pas
d'hommes ici c'est au travail dans les
marais à couper des roseaux atteindront
pas rentrer tu devrais les attendre je
tenais trouve sur la bonne route et vaut
mieux pour vous comme pour moi que je ne
m'attarde pas pourquoi les tartares sont
derrière moi
ils peuvent surgir d'un instant à
l'autre merci non pas par ici beaucoup
il faut pas que tu prennes la route
qu'ils connaissent vient de suis moi
[Musique]
continuez tout droit en suivant c'est
pas mais fait bien attention de ne pas
en sortir le terrain dangereux même pour
ceux qui le connaissent très bien
je prends attention bonne chance merci
[Musique]
m
edwards est un peu par là alors approche
où étais tu es
tu sais très bien le cavalier que nous
cherchons à que vous cachez personne
n'est venu dans ce village personne en
tout cas pour se cacher et je vais te
tuer j'ai été portés sors pas mon mari
qui travaille dans les marais du mans tu
sais où il se cache
tu ferais mieux de parler parce
qu'autrement dessus encore bien pire que
ses parts à un chien qui es tu toi
pauvre femme pauvre idiote suis donc
fier de ce travail elle ya bien de quoi
les générations d'esclaves pour en
arriver là
c'est ce que vous êtes une bande
d'esclaves achetés ou vendus comme du
bétail ou des cochons des bêtes
non
allez allez
oui
k
[Musique]
m
bien
je vais revenir te tirer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ne bougez pas grâce à leurs bons
rires
là d'un bon cheval est enlisée fallait
le sortir de là
au village le village est en peur au feu
[Musique]
et
tous
[Musique]
non
sache que tu arrives et maman qu'ils on
est maman qui déteint tard ils ont mené
tout le monde
pourquoi ont-ils fait ça je vais vous
dire
les en mai
parce qu'ils n'ont pas trouvé ce qu'il
cherchait
mais si vous êtes décidé à vous battre
pour nous la vente âge de terrain
alors on y va
[Musique]
et
si les postes
m
nous avons repéré ils sont est une verse
dissipa plus ils ne vont pas très vite
ils recherchent vos traces on peut les
surprendre
oui en coupant par l'arrêt court si on
peut les devancer
allons-y
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
et voilà tout le monde est à sa place
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allons-y
[Applaudissements]
oh
à
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
m
voilà
à
[Musique]
aho
je remercie je me sens beaucoup mieux
falloir partir
courage merci merci pour tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
adieu mon frère sans toi nous aurions
tout perdu nous avons dû les ce point
nous sommes quittes sans vous j'aurais
disparu au fond des marais à dieu
au revoir
que dieu vous garde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au détail est pas peu ils sont tous
morts
je vais chercher de l'eau
vous êtes du village
cadeau jamais joué je voyage pour les
affaires j'ai aidé les gens du village
avec se terminer cette bande de tartares
je remercie mon cas
qu'est ce qui s'est passé j'étais venu
rendre visite à un oncle il a une troupe
de tartes et rave est arrivé chercher un
homme et le croyez qu'on cachait au
village ils ont mené les femmes ils
n'ont pas tu me suis sauvée j'ai marché
pendant des heures dans les marais sans
espoir à boutte vous mettiez pour le nu
en est serait mort tout seul et doute
vous à quel village
hachey bisque chez bink pourquoi ai je
voulu traverser le fleuve est chez bink
c'est possible non non pourquoi n'y a
plus un seul bac ni passeur je pourrais
sûrement trouver une barque
ça ne sera pas facile puisque vous ne
connaissez personne
merci je me sens beaucoup mieux mais
n'est ce pas vous que les tartares
veulent arrêter
pourquoi dites vous ça bien sûr ça ne me
regarde en rien si je peux vous aider à
traverser le fleuve je le ferais très
volontiers kit que vous soyez il me
semble que je vous dois bien ça et
prenez ce cheval nous avons du chemin à
faire
je vous remercie je m'appelle dimitri ou
yakine crj la naf
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]